[Music]
pedro is with us and he is in hartford
connecticut hi pedro welcome to the
ramsey show
hey how are you dave are you able to
hear me absolutely what's up oh my god
i'm so excited i've been watching it for
the past three years and i'm just
thrilled to be speaking to you
thank you you're going to need to speak
directly into your phone it's a little
bit muffled how can we help
yes so i'm going through um you know me
and my family we are going through a
crisis at the moment
and as a regards to him my my little
brother
and
what is going on is that he's not
respecting some of the boundaries
that we got in place at home
which is causing difficulties
around the house and i wanted to know
how can we uh
move forward as a family as we try to
deal with that situation
how old is he how old is he
he's 17 years old
he's a senior in high school
and
what my mother tried to do
when you try to speak to him i'm like
hey david this is um
what's going on around the house uh you
keep coming in late he's still um you
know smoking marijuana are you still
doing all these things that we don't
want you to do
but david still his name is david but he
still um shows us to
do those actions because he says
your dad's not your dad's not in the
picture
no he's not he's not well we have
different dads his dad live in
dallas texas okay
and how old are you
i'm 22 years old and how many other
siblings does does david have
he has uh well he has a lot of them in
puerto rico but living with him right
now he only has me and his little
brother his little brother's like 13
years old
yeah
and what year is he junior or senior in
high school
i believe he's a senior this year
when does he turn 18
uh
march 4th
okay
march 4th
and
what is
really what has happened is that my mom
is like hey that at some point we cannot
keep living like this it's hurtful you
know we seeing the things that he's
doing
that's um
that's causing harm to himself but it's
also hurting me and my mom because we
love him
but
we uh we just don't know what else to do
dave we tried everything we uh we call
um
bcs i've been in the picture the police
have been in the picture um why were
they where were the police in the
picture
the police was in the picture because he
um
something happened last year i don't
know the exact details uh
i think he was involved with some legal
issues
uh i don't know the exact details but he
i don't know if he spilled something i
think the the police were involved and
that caused bcf to be involved in the
picture okay that's why
ken nor i our family therapist uh dr
john deloney would be ideal to be
sitting here but he's not so
i'll just play uh papa dave grandpa dad
grandpa dave okay
and that's my only expertise in this
which is in other words very limited and
i've never faced something like this
personally so i can't imagine the
heartbreak and
the pain that you and your mom are going
through that this uh
that this young man's misbehavior is
bringing to you uh the only hope i've
ever had um
influencing someone
has not been by force although i've been
tempted to once they once
by someone i mean an adult and this this
young man's old enough and physically
large enough that he's acting out as an
adult and so the only thing you can do
is talk him into it in other words and
the only way i've been able to do that
is put someone that has credibility
someone that he believes in
in his face
and um you know it might be that there's
a a couple of guys at the local church
that you guys are members of would sit
down with him and you
and the four of you uh go out for coffee
and they just look at him and go look
knucklehead you're stuck on stupid and
you're getting ready to have a really
long life if you keep living like this
because come march you're not gonna be
our problem anymore we're putting you on
the street but after that you're gonna
have a long life because knuckleheads
always have a long life
and it's always painful and you're being
a freaking knucklehead and so when are
you gonna straighten up and be a man
instead of a little boy and who's going
to call him out on that where he's going
to listen and i don't know who that is
um but he needs the knucklehead speech
because he's stuck on stupid right now
and we got to unstick him right
absolutely dave
yeah and
you know we i i i i agree with you i
think that somebody who has who he
believes in
can probably help because mom i try mom
try hey pedro let me ask you let me ask
you real quick is is mama paying for
anything that he's benefiting from right
now cell phone car what's what's mama
paying for that he's using
um
phone services at the moment
i mean
take that away tonight i would take
here's here's the thing i think dave's
right on the knucklehead discussion but
i also think that this is a kid who's
who's hurting
and because he's hurting he's hurting
you all and he's lost he's flailing who
knows what all is going on we're not
privy to that but i would tell you
that he's already causing pain for you
and your mom
and and today's point you're not kicking
him out maybe at this point because he's
not 18 yet but i would take away every
benefit
every benefit that she's paying for i
take it away with a very clear
conversation this is why i'm doing this
this isn't working i'm not gonna
subsidize fund this anymore it's gone
and you can start to figure it out on
your own plus the knucklehead speech but
i think she's gotta cut all benefits all
blessings i've been to connecticut and
march it's cold outside yeah i think he
needs to feel some more pain and
desperation
and i i i i don't know i mean look dude
if you want to live here these are the
standards and if you're not going to be
up to those standards by march you're
gone now your mom needs to be able to
back that up and say that and you got to
back her up
and between now and march take stuff
away from him and try to put people in
his life to influence him and help him
um but i don't know how you turn someone
like this sometimes they have to hit the
wall on their own yeah
and until they
until they find some pain they don't
they don't get a wake-up call the
12-steppers talk about that all the time
you have to hit bottom before you you
know and sometimes you hit bottom hard
before you get this stuff but um
you know he's uh
he's mighty cocky for a guy with a warm
pillow
and so um you know we can get him a cold
one that's all i know to do i don't know
how to do it otherwise and that's not
being tough or mean or angry it's tough
love because the current thing we're
doing is creating a juvenile delinquent
and so we have to not keep doing what
we've been doing
we have to try something new and that is
an act of love because it's not going to
be easy for you and her
to watch someone that you love be on the
street
pedro i ask you a quick question the
consequences that are coming from his
behavior are they hurting you and your
mom more or hurting him more
um
i i will say it's hurting him more yeah
i think even though i don't i don't
he's not open to me yeah maybe an
afternoon maybe an afternoon lunch at
the homeless shelter would be good for
him yeah
that's where he gonna be boy
yeah yeah and then i know that
he um
he doesn't want um he has some mental
health issues they're not act
bad but he doesn't want to that's a
whole different equation you just change
it right we offer her yeah right we
offer him say like dude like we can help
you when i see someone and we're there
for you if i deny everything from what
i'm trying to give them yeah if you want
to stay here here's the rules
and you're going to do these things
you're going to be in on time we're not
smoking pot we're not stealing stuff and
you're seeing a counselor that will pay
for
if you're not willing to do these things
then we are not going to participate in
your downfall we love you too much for
that
and that's what some people call tough
love i think it's just called love
actually but um and i don't know how to
do that other than that if there's some
way you can love this guy well and some
other way you can put your arm around
him and walk with him that's softer or
gentler than that i would try to find
that
because that that's a very harsh
um
thing we're discussing here but i
ultimately that's where you're headed um
because you know
enabling does not help anyone uh just
putting up with it in other words
doesn't make anybody get better
uh never has uh you got to do the work
to decide and ouch
the hard thing the hard thing dude and
keep in mind none of us are licensed
therapists to give you advice we're just
a couple of old farts giving you our
best shot at it
this is the ramsey show